these other things are just offshoots  what they what they really think is we  ought to be there and want to get out i  know we ought to be there  but uh  i can't get out  i just can't be the architect of  surrender  and uh don't see i'm trying everywhere  in the world i can to find a way  to uh thing but they they don't have the  pressure that bring them to the table as  of yet we don't know where they ever  will i'm willing to do damn near  anything if i told you what i was  willing to do  i wouldn't have any program dirksen  wouldn't give me a dollar to operate the  war  i just can't  i can't  operate in a glass bowl with all these  things but  i'm willing to do nearly anything the  human can do if i can do it with any  honor at all but uh  they started with me on gym you remember  he was corrupt and he ought to be killed  so we killed him we all got together and  got a goddamn  bunch of thugs and we went in  assassinated now we really had no  political stability since then